assalam alaykum greetings of peace I
have some incredible amazing news to
share with you after serving
45 years in the church as a priest David
Embraces Islam named himself abdurahman
which means the servant of the most
merciful one it's a very amazing story
Australian priest old David converts to
Islam submission to the will of the
creator of the heavens and Earth that's
what Islam means let's continue on with
the story in a Twist gold David a highly
respected priest from Australia has
recently made Headlines by announcing
his conversion to Islam after dedicating
45 years of his life to the church
taking on the name Abdul
rman as his new Muslim name that's a
beautiful name because it means servant
of the merciful one cuz God Almighty
Allah is the most loving the most
compassionate the most merciful this
news has captured the attention and
sparked extensive conversations within
religious circles as people are eager to
understand the motivations behind his
decisions people want to know what drove
this man with the billion dooll hate
spreading misinformation industry you
have people like this who are accepting
Islam now the background of R David G
David had earned respect as a priest
within the Australian Church Christian
Community for four and a half decades
get this four and a half decades he
served diligently in the church earning
admiration for his commitment to his
faith at the time many young Christians
looked up to him as a figure a Christian
figure the news of L David conversion to
Islam submission to the Creator not the
creation caught many by surprise he
adopted a name servant of the most
merciful abdurahman which means as I was
saying servant of the merciful one David
has wholeheartedly embraced the
teachings of Islam submission to the
will of the Creator and while specific
reasons for his choice remain somewhat
unclear at the moment of this report
people are quite
curious as I'm sure you are about why he
made that decision and they want to know
more about this religion of Islam some
people are worried about how his
conversion will affect the community
While others are very happy with his
choice and have shown their support the
Quran holds significance in Islam as it
is believed to be the words of the
creator the heavens and earth God
Almighty Allah it serves as a Guiding
Light and a source of inspiration for
Muslims across the globe now as we see
many people out there are thinking that
Islam is growing by the rapid numbers
because of the great birth rates Islam
really caus people to hold firmly to
family commitment to not have boyfriends
and girlfriends Jump Around around from
nightclub to nightclub getting drunk and
being promiscuous but to stay away from
things that are harmful for the Mind
Body and the soul and to get your act
right and have what's called a nikah
Islamic nikah this is marriage and from
there have children and what happens
here is that many of our conservative
friends and Christians now they're
seeing that many many Muslims are having
so many kids so many children so they
they're encouraging their congregations
to hey if you don't want these Muslims
surpass you got to start having kids but
that is not what it is that's uh one
part of the component it's things like
this it's when people like priest of 45
years David when he looks into the
continuity of the message from Adam
peace be upon him the first man who was
told to submit his will to the creator
of heavens and earth he did Islam
submission to the will of God so this
might go over your head because you're
like hey the truth is there but you're
not paying attention to it but he was
paying attention to it so he saw the
cont continuity of the chain of
Revelation going from Adam and then
going to the rest of the the prophets
and Messengers who all came with the
same message not a trinity not God being
a man having a son none of these things
but pure monotheism and just to name a
few of the messengers ishmail Isaac
David Solomon they all came with Islam
submission to the will of one in only
one God and being morally upright
adhering to the commands of God being
obedient being loyal to the one God and
then you have Noah you have Moses Noah
Abraham Jesus peace be upon him and the
last and final messenger sent the
mankind Propet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him and he came with
the ultimate miracle and people are
looking not at this book just from the
outside from the inside reading it and
they're loving the message of the pure
monotheism the purpose of life the
Hereafter where you going with you when
you die this is amazing story I wanted
to share with you and I'm going to give
you a gift for S through this and if you
want to understand this way of life even
more just like the Australian piece the
40 look the Australian priest of 45
years of 45 years he's obviously
well-versed in Christianity with all due
respect to our Christian friends and
neighbors and now what happens he looks
into Islam obviously we want to get his
story so if you can connect us to David
David we like to have you on a program
to get more in deep in depth into what
made you make that decision to put it
all on the line to go against all of the
Fabrications and lies and all of the
hate that spewed against Islam you saw
past all of that garbage all of that
junk and you saw the treasure and the
contentment and peace and proof and
evidences that Islam provides and you
took that brave and courageous step so
connect with us and if you want to
connect with the way of life the book
that now he looked into the Quran verba
and word of God Almighty we'll get it to
you for free go to the Deans show.com
we'll send it to you for free thank you
guys and uh Amazing Story Amazing Story
subscribe hit that notification Bell and
we see you next time peace be with you
asalam
Alum alhamdulillah brothers and sisters
we've acquired the future Dean Center
property and we want to get the mhid
open first it's all coming along we're
installing the doors we can make woo
we've installed the carpets we have many
details to finish up but it's coming
along alhamdulillah we need a new roof
we need new windows and we need a minb
that's right we need a Min for the
musjid now if all of you want to be a
part of history and help build a house
of worship build a musjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you